[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory in
today's video we're going to be
discussing you guessed it harry potter
theories
however they're not my own theories
they're theories that have been floating
around the internet for many years
and what do all of these theories have
in common well all of them were actually
confirmed to be true years later either
through jk rowling or through pottermore
some of them might be obvious to you now
but at one point a lot less was known
about the wizarding world and it's only
through extended law that we've been
able to find definitive proof to support
our theories i make a lot of theories of
my own so i can only hope that my own
theories are confirmed one day anyway
without further ado here are 10 harry
potter fan theories that actually turned
out to be true 1. harry's children's
names in the epilogue we see harry
sending his children after hogwarts in a
familiar scene in platform 9 in three
quarters at this stage of harry and
jenny's relationship they now have three
children james sirius lily luna and
albus severus however what stuck out to
some fans were the choices that harry
had made for his children's names he
named his kids after people that were
important to him but there was a
distinct absence of names of other
notable figures in harry's life people
like arthur hagrid and most related to
this theory remus
the theory on the internet was that
harry didn't name his son after remus
because he thought that teddy lupin
remus's son might like to use the name
for his own kids down the line it turns
out this was exactly right and was
actually confirmed by rolling on twitter
2. dudley dursley dudley dursley was the
bane of harry's existence tormenting him
for a large portion of his childhood
even when he would return home to little
whinging solely for the summer holidays
however on one visit in the summer of
1995 dudley would have quite a wake-up
call
after bullying harry with his group of
friends the pair began walking home and
it's at this stage that they're brutally
attacked by dementors dudley is of
course a target of the attack and
afterwards the book poses the following
dementors caused a person to relive the
worst moments of their life what would
spoiled pampered bullying dudley have
been forced to hear this caused much
speculation among fans but the
prevailing theory actually ended up
being the right one as it was confirmed
in an interview with rowling in 2004
my feeling is that he saw himself
exactly for what he was and for a boy
that spoiled it would be terrifying
three magical schools hogwarts is the
most famous wizarding school in the
harry potter story i don't think you
could argue that it's the school with
the sorting hat the hogwarts express and
the whomping willow however jk rowling
at one point revealed to the fans that
other schools existed in the wizarding
world with fans immediately jumping to
all kinds of conclusions about where
these other schools might be just before
the release of the fantastic beasts film
rolling took to pottermore to reveal
that there are 11 unique schools for
witchcraft and wizardry across the world
these schools include ilvermorny north
america cold off tourettes russia
mahutukuro japan
bobaton france hogwarts uk
castelo brushu south america durmstrang
eastern europe and ugadu africa as well
as a few others that have yet to be
named
four hermines and mortenshia encounter
in the half blood prince horus loghorn
takes over as potions master and it's
not long after he accepts the position
that he begins to expose students to all
sorts of powerful potions the potion in
question here however is amortentia and
wartensia is the most powerful love
potion in the world it is distinctive
for its mother of pearl sheen and steam
rises from the potion in spirals and
mortensia smells different to each
person according to what attracts them
in the half bud prince hermione herself
takes a whiff of the emertensha smelling
freshly mown grass new parchment and one
last thing which wasn't explicitly
stated fans however strongly theorized
that the missing smell the one that
hermione wouldn't reveal was in fact the
smell of ron weasley's hair this turned
out to be true and the reason it wasn't
revealed was because it would have
spoiled the buildup of their mutual
attraction
5. the death eaters are based on the
nazis blood status is one of the most
controversial aspects of the wizarding
world a concept in which wizarding
families can be distinguished by the
level of magically endowed family
members generally speaking people are
slotted into one of the following
categories pure blood half blood or
muggle and the different classifications
of blood purity in the wizarding world
actually act in a very similar fashion
to race in the real world which
obviously leaves the door open for
things like prejudice for this reason
many fans were quick to recognize
similarities between voldemort and the
death eaters with a certain german
leader and his own followers these
similarities as it turned out were not
an accident as the depressingly
realistic depiction of comparable
regimes was later confirmed by
i wanted harry to leave our world and
find exactly the same problems in the
wizarding world so you have the intent
to impose a hierarchy you have bigotry
and this notion of purity which is this
great fallacy but it crops up all over
the world people like to think
themselves superior and that if they can
pride themselves in nothing else they
can pride themselves on perceived purity
so yeah that follows a parallel to
nazism 6. the baby in limbo when harry
travels to the forbidden forest in
deathly hallows it's not long before
he's struck down by voldemort the next
thing we know harry's beginning to
regain consciousness from here he
quickly realizes that he's no longer in
the forbidden forest
in fact entirely disoriented he didn't
know where he was all he knew was that
it was unlike any other place that he
had been before
this place as it turned out was a sort
of limbo
one of the most interesting aspects of
harry's visit to limbo was the ominous
presence of a sort of baby i used that
term loosely lying on the ground it's
never actually explained properly what
this thing was which obviously caused
fans to speculate and theorize the
prevailing theory was that this thing
was voldemort and fans turned out to be
correct i've been asked this a lot it is
the last piece of soul voldemort
possesses when voldemort attacks harry
they both fall temporarily unconscious
and both their souls harry's undamaged
and healthy voldemorts stunted and
maimed appear in the limbo where harry
meets dumbledore 7. flying without a
broom in the wizarding world we're
basically taught to believe that flight
is only capable with the use of a
broomstick however in the seventh book
fans were thrown off as voldemort was
suddenly described as being able to fly
through the sky
this caused many fans to speculate and
theorize as to why and how this was
possible the prevailing theory was that
using a broom is just like using a wand
not always entirely necessary as we know
using a wand allows a witch or wizard to
channel their magic however if the witch
or wizard is powerful enough they don't
always have a need for a wand this is
called wonderless magic i can only
imagine that flying follows the same
principles with most witches wizards
requiring a broom to channel flight jk
rowling later states that all wizards
have the power of flight innately but
that the vast vast majority need a broom
to achieve it
8. voldemort made even more horcruxes
than we knew of may horcrux is an object
in which a dark witch or wizard has
imbued part of their soul the ultimate
purpose of creating a horcrux is to
achieve immortality there are only two
known wizards who have created a horcrux
the first being herper the fowl and the
second being voldemort who produced
numerous
voldemort is widely known to have
created seven horcruxes tom biddle's
diary marvolo gaunt's ring salazar
slytherin's locket helga hufflepuff's
cup rowena ravenclaw's diadem nakini and
lastly harry potter however what many
fans have speculated over the years is
that voldemort made even more horcruxes
than we and dumbledore were aware of
this theory was later confirmed on
pottermore where it was revealed that
professor quirrell was in fact a
temporary horcrux and that voldemort's
presence in his body was corrupting him
from the inside out 9. magic is genetic
very little is revealed in the harry
potter story about the origins of magic
it's an enigmatic present that seems to
sort of choose some and not others
however despite the lack of information
on the topic fans began to theorize what
makes someone magical could it be
genetic as it turns out that's actually
true
and it was confirmed by rowling people
who can practice magic have a magical
gene however that certainly doesn't mean
that the magical gene is restricted to
those who already have it in their
bloodline as it can suddenly appear in
both squibs and muggles
10. the cast of hogwarts for centuries
the children of the magical world have
been receiving their hogwarts acceptance
letters the moment they convey they can
expect a letter their door and the
letter is symbolic in that it represents
a new chapter in their lives this letter
in essence means that they will be able
to attend hogwarts school of witchcraft
and wizardry the world's finest
wizarding school however after the
series ended many fans were still
scratching their heads and wondering how
much does hogwarts cost there were many
fan theories about this ranging from
scholarships to secret donors but one of
the prevailing theories was that the
school was in fact free this theory as
it turns out was later confirmed by
rowling who tweeted the following
there's no tuition fee the ministry of
magic covers the cost of all magical
education and that's it for this video
were you guys in agreeance with these
theories before they were eventually
confirmed through twitter and pottermore
comment down below also if you guys are
interested i've been posting a fair bit
on my mythology channel link in the
description until next time remember
happiness can be found even in the
darkest of times if one only remembers
to turn on the light